et alexandre baradez êtes avec nous sur
ce plateau bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes analyste des marchés chez
easy jet france on regardait un ce sujet
sur le système interbancaire swift est
ce que cela pourrait être efficace de
prendre une telle sanction d'exclure la
russie de ce système interbancaire se
serait efficace et c'est un petit peu
l'âme nucléaire des négociations il ya
deux groupes en que les alliés sont en
train d'évaluer c'est la question de
l'accès au système swift et la question
d'un embargo ou de mesures restrictives
sur la partie énergie dont on sait que
c'est une partie des revenus de la
russie il y avait une l'ancien ministre
des finances russe en 2014 au monde les
tensions en crimée avait estimé que si
la russie était coupé du système swift
sap est vrai à l'époque 5% de son pib
par an absolument gigantesque qui veut
dire que si la disney ça avec des
sanctions de des mesures de rétorsion
sur les exportations de produits tech
par exemple plus gel des avoirs plus
j'allais avoir rue dans les différentes
banques et que vous ajoutez décide des
sanctions sur le sur le dollar par
exemple
cc c'est un coup fort à l'économie russe
qui sera très probablement récession
l'année même où les sanctions seront
seront prononcées donc on voit que c'est
c'est tout le monde à nice avec beaucoup
de précaution parce que on voit que les
veaux en italie par exemple ce matin
comme mario draghi a dit il faut se
préparer à une crise de l'énergie et
voir comment a commencé à me doubler
vente ou le mans les les sanctions et
voir l'impact sur l'économie donc moins
bien conscience que si on va sur ce
créneau là derrière l'ordre de se
préparer effectivement à subir une crise
énergétique temporaire oui parce que on
sent bien qu'au sein de l'europe il n'y
a pas de consensus autour de cette
exclusion de la russie du du système
swift l'allemagne par exemple et est
très dépendante du gaz russe
expliquez-nous 7 cette dépendance par
rapport au système swift parce qu'on
doit payer en fait les importations de
gaz via ce système ces satanés tout ce
qui est
livraison et règlements se passe par ce
système là quelques sources lierre qui
indiquaient que certains acheteurs de
pétrole russe était déjà confrontée à
des problèmes de lettres de crédit dans
des banques occidentales pour régler la
russie donc sap a été convenu de manière
officielle mais ce qui veut dire qu'on
n'en ont reçu que des messages comme ça
la réussite en disant voilà nous aussi
acheteur de pétrole si on commence à
nous on a conscience que si on bloque
l'accès au dollar vous ne pourrez plus
vous réglez on sera plus livrés mais on
commence déjà à manier un petit peu ça
cet argument là donc c'est une vraie
menace et hier biden a également
mentionné comme ça en indiquant que
l'objectif de l'ald des états unis est
de limiter aussi la capacité de la
russie à faire du business pour prendre
ces termes en dollar et au yen est
plutôt hier c'était le re munich
expliquait que voilà plus d'accès aux
marchés de capitaux britanniques donc
plus loin de lever de la dette même si
on sait que la russie a pas trop
anticiper on va être leur vis-à-vis de
cette date voilà elle avait rêvé
liquidée par exemple tous ces occasions
tous ses avoirs en bons du trésor
américain par exemple pour les rendre
liquide mais attention que cette cette
capacité à avoir vendu ses bons du
trésor américains donc libellés en
dollars ça génère quand même de
liquidités en dollars qu'il faut comme
stocker toute cette l'équité n'est pas
stocké en russie et c'est là que le gel
des avoirs peut avoir un rôle important
et qui plus est si vous comment ça fera
pas en plus le poutine on voit que c'est
des sources qui laisse entendre que
c'est une réflexion qui est évalué
actuellement au sein de l'union
européenne de sanctionner directement à
la dir poutine alors justement ça a été
décidée il ya eu un accord des 27 pour
sanctionner vladimir poutine et sergueï
lavrov pour le gel de leurs avoirs
concrètement pour nous téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que cela implique concrètement
ce gel des avoirs alors déjà il faudra
réussir localiser les avoir donc ça
c'est une partie que koenig qui n'est
pas de mon domaine mais c'est tout ce
qui est extra territorial en fait sur
lequel vous avez la capacité de ba de
geler les biens mobiliers les comptes
bancaires saisir des yachts par exemple
1 2 de deux proches de poutine des
oligarques donc c'est ces sanctions qui
on entend parfois les contre-arguments
dire oui mais cette sanction là n'est
pas efficace par exemple dire la russie
ne peut plus lever de capitaux ou ne
plus se financer sur les marchés
capitaux oui à une dette qui est faible
mais c'est si vous à signer toutes les
sanctions classification si vous
additionnez gel des avoirs incapacité de
lever de la dette incapacité de faire du
business en yens et en livres en dollars
c'est l'accumulation de tout ça qui fait
qu'à m'en donnez vous à les acculer
l'économie russe
et calmez vous allez devoir ramener la
russie la table des négociations mais le
gros stress que nous avons nous en
europe c'est qu'effectivement on est
dépendant du gaz l'allemagne dis qu'on a
quand même des stocks de gaz pour
l'ensemble de l'année et qu'il faut par
contre pensez à reconstituer les stocks
pour l'hiver prochain donc ça se fait en
été ça sent que ça se fait en était mais
ça peut aussi dire qu'on a comme le
temps de faire venir des gaz naturel
liquéfié par exemple ce qui était fait
déjà indépendamment mais il ya pas d
infrastructures c'est très clair en
allemagne par exemple il faudra deux à
trois ans et ce qui est estimée pour
construire un schéma d'infrastructures
pour rendre ce gaz liquéfié or opéra le
est opérationnel sur l'allemagne mais à
m'en donnait effectivement le robot doit
faire des choix stratégiques et on est
confronté et pour bien comprendre toutes
ces sanctions qui sont prises elles ont
un effet elles vont avoir un effet
immédiat où on verra cela sur plusieurs
mois et donc du coup est ce que la
temporalité n'est pas la même sur les
sanctions et sur le terrain or ça qu'on
estime que les premières sanctions la
typiquement gel des avoirs et cetera des
avoirs de bank ça commence à nous tous
qui les restrictions d'exportations de
produits high tech ou de composants
également pour le tout ce qui est
industries d'extraction en fait un de
matières premières sassou va commencer à
se mesurer sur quelques semaines donc il
ya quelques semaines pour mesurer ça
mais c'est sûr que c'est c'est pas une
sanction qui peuvent tout de suite tous
et l'économie russe au bordeaux bord de
la falaise parce que on voit tout ce qui
fait qu on va dire poutine a pris les
devants à organiser une économie en
termes de réserves de change en termes
de réserves d'or également pour pouvoir
tenir que quelques temps et puis faites
m'en il yal allié chinois qui peut
servir aussi de contrepartie quand il
allait quitter qu'il veut sur la partie
européenne ou américaine et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que là on aurait aussi du
côté de la chine on écoute un peu la d
re le propos du président chinois il ya
un petit peu tout on voit que il
reconnaît sa souveraineté de l'ukraine
au niveau de la chine mais le président
chinois a dit que en gros ils
soutenaient comme l'action de la russie
de la condamnation a pas de convention
si on n'accepte pas donc plus fort ce
forcément là c'est l'aspect militaire
mais la chine dénonce les mesures
unilatérales prises voilà donc la chine
est entré deux parce qu'il faut quand
même bien voir que la chine n'a pas non
plus intérêt à ce que ça aille trop loin
parce que la chine a ralenti son
économie volontairement qu'une politique
zéro co vide par rapport aux jeux
olympiques
et notamment et que c'est dans cette
phase post jeux olympiques où l'avion
son économie se redéploie assez
rapidement elle a besoin d'un moteur
export qui est très fort et si la crise
russe commence entraîner l'économie
mondiale dans une phase récessive ce qui
risque une des victimes collatérales et
pas des moindres sera la chine donc et
aussi un intérêt pour la chine d'un
point de vue économique sortie des jeux
olympiques sortie de phases qu'ovide
assez intense d'avoir moto export très
fort sachant que c'est en économie
domestique est fragilisé par les taux
immobiliers qui est assez assez malmené
en ce moment merci beaucoup alexandre
baradez ce pour toutes ces explications